[Music]
what up guys goes in here for anime
uproar and today we are going to be
talking about how strong the demon king
is right now right now he is fighting
bond and Mele Otis and the question is
do they have a chance to defeat this
so-called God I'll be exploring that
question in this video make sure to LIKE
and subscribe for more seven deadly sins
videos leave suggestions of videos you
would like to see in the comments feel
free to follow us on Instagram and tell
me what's your favorite seven deadly
sins meme we've got posted there and or
send me some of your favorite memes
memes have become a bit of an obsession
for me lately anyways keep in mind there
will be cutting edge spoilers ahead
you've been warned and now without
further ado let's get into it let's go
over what we know about the demon king
he is the ruler of the demon clan a clan
that could only be challenged and
strength by the goddess clan in chapter
1 3 3 after meliodas temporarily dies he
has a conversation with his father -
demon king although we don't see the
demon king at this point we find out
that he is very powerful not only did he
create the commandments Mele Otis also
says that he put a curse on him so that
he comes back to life indefinitely
despite how strong and comely Otis
usually is the demon king consents that
malleolus is trembling in his presence
possibly because of fear the fact that
Mele Otis the opie and seemingly
invincible character we have come to
know so well trembles in the demon
King's presence shows how powerful the
demon king must be we find out that each
time le Otis dies his father feeds on
his emotions and store strength inside
him by doing so he says he hopes to
restore malleolus to the all-powerful
demon he once was we later discover more
details about the curse malleolus
mentioned in Chapter 224 Mele Otis
explains that both he and Elizabeth were
cursed even though he was a demon he
sided with the goddesses he betrayed and
killed his own kind that was his crime
though she was a goddess
Elizabeth associated with demons her
crime was rescuing the 10 commandments
when asked who they were punished by
Mele Otis says to gods he is of course
referring to the demon king and the
supreme deity the fact that malleolus
refers to them not as simply rulers but
odds points to how powerful they must be
Mellie Otis and Elizabeth were powerless
to do anything against the demon king
and the supreme deities overwhelming
might the demon king and supreme deity
cursed them with eternal life formerly
Otis and eternal reincarnation for
Elizabeth this is why Mellie Otis stops
aging and always comes back to life when
he is killed every time one of
Elizabeth's reincarnations regains its
memories no matter what she is destined
to die in three days every time she is
reborn
she is fated to meet and fall in love
with Mellie Otis only to lose her life
before his eyes the Elizabeth we know is
the hundred and seventh Elizabeth so
Mellie Otis has already had to watch his
love die 106 times ironically this
punishment of the demon king and the
supreme DB ensures that both of their
children will be safe from death no
matter what the fact that the demon king
with the supreme goddesses help has the
power to completely break the rules of
the world the rules of life and death
shows how strong he must be what's more
as meliodas reveals only the demon king
and supreme deity have the power to
break the curse
he needs an equivalent power if he
wishes to break it this is why he seeks
out the ten commandments and
accidentally makes his body a vessel for
his father who that not only breaks the
curse on Mellie Otis that is keeping him
from aging but also says that he can
break the curse that keeps reincarnating
Elizabeth - he is supposedly strong
enough to do both without any help from
the supreme deity keep in mind when the
demon king punished the powerless
meliodas
that was not all of his power as
explained in chapter 247 when the demon
king decided to bring the vast chaotic
demon world under his reign he split his
power strength in half and granted it to
his servant with the plan to take
control all of it at once the power he
was given was so great that he tried to
revolt and this threatened the demon
King's own position so he came up with a
more efficient method he split that
power into ten fragments and granted it
to ten hand-picked warriors these
Warriors became the 10 commandments
Mellie Otis at first plans to get all of
these commandments and by doing so he
thinks he will gain power on par with
the demon king unfortunately though this
is a trap as the demon king explains to
absorb them all and become the new demon
king is to be
come his new vessel at some point in the
distant past the demon king also
presented Merlin with detailed
information on all the secret arts and
mysteries of the underworld and divine
protection that could defend against the
brainwashing of the goddesses when
Merlin still turned down the demon king
and supreme deity they work together to
destroy the city of beli allowin where
she was from ironically even though the
Wizards of beli Alwyn stayed neutral the
demon king and supreme deity completely
crushed them by causing it to rain
curses and mists of death Hellfire and
lightning over the city for over 1,000
days thus from this little backstory we
get we learned that when considering how
strong the demon king is we must think
into account his vast knowledge of the
underworld and the fact that he has
certain kinds of protection against the
goddess clan additionally what the
goddesses help although we don't know if
he actually needed her help he was able
to rain destruction down on a city for
1,000 days straight now that's
definitely a godly amount of power but
let's address the demon king we met in
purgatory as we know
while most demons were sealed away in
the coffin of eternal darkness at the
end of the holy war the demon king was
imprisoned in purgatory when bond goes
to purgatory we get better acquainted
with the demon king he's absolutely
gigantic and we figured out that he
continually gains energy by greedily
consuming all the living things in
purgatory and he is constantly growing
larger now this is the demon king
without the power of the ten
commandments and without the power he is
letting zelgius borrow nevertheless this
version of him has to be more than equal
to the power of the ten commandments by
now because the Ten Commandments were
half of his power three thousand years
ago this purgatory version of him has
clearly been getting stronger since then
in fact even being able to survive in
purgatory under the harsh conditions is
an accomplishment bond could only do
this because he was immortal but he
still had to deal with being burnt to
ashes freezing to the bone rotting from
deadly poison and so on until his body
eventually adjusted the demon king not
only has to be ridiculously strong to
survive in those conditions but he
thrived in them time passes by
differently in purgatory than in the
outside world the passing of one minute
is like a year so that would suggest
that the demon king spent over one and a
half billion years in purgatory
observe
bring more power to get that figure I
simply googled how many minutes would be
in 3000 years and then since one minute
equals one year that would give us the
number of years the demon king spent in
purgatory even if the number of years
that the demon king spent in purgatory
is not over 1 billion the demon king
himself has stated that at the very
least the numbers in the hundreds of
millions keep in mind the creatures of
purgatory are not weak bond and
malleolus as emotions together could
barely beat one purgatory creature when
they first tried so you can begin to
imagine how strong the purgatory part of
the demon king has grown according to
the official translation wild Hawks
brother fought against the demon king
120,000 118 times before bond and Mele
Otis's emotions meet up with him and all
120 thousand 118 times the demon king
has won when they first fight the demon
king bond Mele Otis's emotions and wild
are completely powerless against him his
magic the ruler ensures that all attacks
like Mele Otis's full counter and bond
snatch heal and reinforced the demon
king instead of doing damage to him fast
forward and the next thing you know our
gang has lost to the demon king 6090
three times
according to Mele Otis at this point
they've challenged the demon king for 60
years and after all that time they
haven't even reached his feet they try
one more time and fail again
but the 60 years have not been for
nothing because bond learned to not only
take energy but to give it too because
every time he tried to steal the demon
Kings power he gave him power instead
they also used this information to
figure out what the secret behind the
demon Kings ruler magic is as malleolus
explains it is a form of reversal it
changes any attack in weakening
maneuvers made against him into healing
and strengthening ones by trying to give
him power bond is actually able to bring
the demon king to his knees so in many
ways bond is the key to defeating this
otherwise near invincible magic ability
unfortunately for bond the demon king
can simply deactivate this ability so
that bond giving him power no longer
hurts him but the beauty of it is that
now other people can do damage to him
once deactivated in theory magic attacks
that would have simply healed him and
made him stronger should now be able to
cause damage it is possible that this is
why melioidosis emotions were able to do
so much damage against demon king so
let's fast forward to demon king
possessed meliodas
as mentioned the demon king seems to
lift the curse that keeps veliotis his
body from aging and he says that he can
lift the curse from elizabeth the demon
king says that he wanted a fresh young
powerful body and melly otis was
seemingly the perfect fit it was set up
so that whoever absorbed all ten
commandments which would in theory allow
someone strong enough to challenge the
demon king himself that person would
become a vessel for the demon king to
inhabit instead in melioidosis body the
demon king is able to easily best
everyone present from mile with sunshine
to king in his new form to Merlin and so
on he is even able to break through the
perfect hue like it was nothing just a
reminder the perfect cube is supposed to
reject entry of all but the caster of
the spell we are told that the cube
deflects all attacks based in the magic
world size and power are irrelevant even
the battle between assault mode Mele
Otis and the one mode ESCA nor didn't
break the cube yet seemingly without
using absolute cancel simply through
brute force the demon king breaks the
perfect cube surrounding Hawke clearly
this is a level of power we haven't seen
before
well what sunshine the star who defeated
the original demon is told by his
brother lunar shell to stop he tells him
that he can't possibly compete against
an opponent like the demon king Merlin
warns that magical attacks won't work
likely referring to his ruler reversal
ability which she likely learned about
when the demon king passed on his
knowledge about the underworld to her so
long ago the gang launches physical
attacks at him but the demon king takes
care of everyone without breaking a
sweat it is only when bond arrives that
we see the demon king phase it was
likely the speed that bond used to save
hawk that caught the demon king by
surprise bond with his snatch ability in
purgatory trained body is able to wipe
the smug smile off the demon King's face
with a punch as the other characters
noticed bond goes blow-for-blow with the
demon king nevertheless the King seems
to get the upper hand on bond when bond
points out that he is not alone
by the oldest emotions are inside
malleolus is body fighting the demon
king so now we have Mellie Otis fighting
on the inside and bond on the outside
hopefully this two front battle will
allow Mellie Otis to kick the demon king
out of his body as bond suggested so we
can assume that demon king possessed
Mellie Otis is strong enough to still be
bond if it wasn't for Mellie Otis's
emotions who are distracting him on the
inside then there's a question of how
much of the demon king is inside Mellie
Otis is it just a 10 commandments part
of the demon king that's in Mellie Otis
or has the purgatory demon king
transferred into Mellie Otis as well
either way Mellie Otis and bond are
taking on a character that is considered
to have godly amounts of power and if
either one of them were taking him on
alone at this point they would likely
lose my guess is that there's still a
part of the demon king trapped in
purgatory and that because this part was
growing for at least hundreds of
millions of years it is stronger than
the part that is taking control of
Mellie Otis Mellie Otis and bond might
succeed in beating this part of the
demon king then this parts power might
be absorbed to create a stronger Mellie
Otis who will then challenge his father
for a final battle or this power might
return to the demon king in purgatory
making the demon king more powerful than
he's ever been as things stand the demon
king in one hole the Ten Commandments
and his purgatory self included is
probably the strongest character right
now perhaps even stronger than the
supreme deity because of the fact that
he's been absorbing power in purgatory
for so long and that is how strong I
believe the demon king is right now
there isn't a better enemy that the
seven deadly sins could be facing at the
moment as far as I'm concerned anyways
thanks for watching the video if you
enjoyed it make sure to smash that like
button to let me know if you haven't be
sure to subscribe and hit that
notification bell for more 7 Deadly Sins
content follow us on instagram at anime
up roar for daily 7 Deadly Sins memes
and feel free to send me some of your
favorites you can also support the
channel by buying awesome anime inspired
shirts like Eskin or praise the sun and
melly Otisfield iraq we even have a
demon king malleolus shirt in the works
so keep an eye out for that
fans either channel can get a whole 25%
off just go to anime up for calm
use the code uproar 25 at checkout a
huge thank you goes out to our
supporters over on patreon especially to
our pro hero tier patrons keelon and the
one and only Gilgamesh if you like what
we do and it gives you value you can
also support our content by pledging as
little as $1 a month and your name will
even be featured in future videos among
these awesome people here the link to
our patreon is in the description thanks
again for all of your support and until
next time see us space cowboys
[Music]
you
[Music]